one of the reasons we didn't get the Red
Wave is because the independence and the
disaffected Liberals they either stayed
home or they they stayed primarily with
the Democrat Party Ron DeSantis clearly
can bring those people in how do I know
that well I even got a guy like Bill
Maher to admit that he could vote for
DeSantis and there's no way in high hell
he could vote for Trump if California
yeah says I have to take shots
and DeSantis says I don't
hello Florida
that's what I'll say about DeSantis
he's a good dude he's a good dude
he really is and he doesn't care whether
you smoke weed and he doesn't care who
you marry just he doesn't but to sound
like the uh
voiceover and a movie that's coming out
soon
[ __ ] just got real
but like for me personally really [ __ ]
just got real with that yeah and that's
that's in my mind I left this place
because of it and I don't want to leave
the leave this place that it would be
very hard
so that is the standard bearer of
liberalism arguing that there is a
situation where the Biden Administration
or the Democrat States the blue States
got so out of whack that he could vote
for DeSantis I don't mean to make this
all about Bill Maher okay and I get it
this election time like he was on TV on
MSNBC and a bunch of other things
telling people to vote for Democrats to
save democracy so my my work will still
continue I think I'm doing the show in
January and I'll I'll push him once
again uh but the idea that okay he he
does represent an important sliver of
American society of the people that can
move one way or another and he's saying
hey he could do the DeSantis thing
that's interesting but let's talk about
the broader picture here it's not about
Trump or DeSantis or even the left it
really isn't all of these leaders good
bad ugly they're the consequence of us
the American voter that is just the
truth it's what we put out there is what
they reflect back to us and regardless
of political party Americans are
obviously fed up everyone in this town
in D.C there are all walking around
today going what in the high hell is
going on here so whether they know it or
not they're yearning to return to a time
of normalcy and comfortability I really
think that's it people want competency